just when the city was reopening is
Lester looming towards a local lockdown
there's been a rise in cases and it's
worrying many including business owners
Mahmood Adan only restarted a few weeks
ago it is really scary because we just
started talking and things started
chesty little bit move and now this news
that is possibility of a lockdown we
look down and that is really speed scary
about as a local business a quarter of
the city's total cases have happened in
the last two weeks
some of them among staff at this
sandwich-making factory the company said
the numbers were small just a handful
testing positive
Lester's public health teams have spent
the weekend analyzing the data hoping to
plot where the cases are one MP in the
city is already calling for a local
lockdown we need to protect lives and we
need to ensure that there is a localized
lockdown that addresses the problem
follows the data and based on the data
we ensure that people do are indeed
protected and that lives are indeed safe
the Department of Health says it's
supporting Lester's response deploying
mobile testing units across the city but
the council says it needs the results of
these tests more quickly if decisions
about localized knockdowns have to be
made it's very difficult to know how a
local lockdown would work certainly
there are no precedents for it and no
guidance for it if we were to give
advice to people to to stay at home it
would at this stage only be advice and
it will have to be based on a very
thorough analysis of what the figures
are telling us we don't yet know what a
local lockdown might look like the
incident director for public health
England said as lockdown restrictions
eased across the rest of the country
we understand that tighter restrictions
in Leicester will be difficult but it's
important that we all play our part to
contain this local outbreak much depends
on how quickly and effectively any new
cases like those here can be jumped on
they have to be contained by testing
contact tracing and isolating people if
not there's a risk the virus will spread
into the wider community a decision
could be made in the coming days Lester
is worried no one here wants another
lockdown but restrictions could well be
re-imposed if clusters of cases continue
Laura bandik Sky News Leicester